the alt shift x podcast has three
episodes out now
there's an interview with cm kozeman the
creator of that crazy sci-fi story all
tomorrows
and there's a two-part interview with
the authors of the expanse
they're both really fun conversations
and you can watch now
at the links below the podcast is on
youtube and spotify
and every podcast app alt
schwift x has also been busy there's
a seven hour long video all about song
of ice and fire theories
and the 100th episode of the game of
thrones abridged podcast came out
there are also a couple of video essays
about bojack horseman
and death and stuff and there's now an
alt shwift x gaming channel playing dark
souls and the binding of isaac
some people think that alt swift x is
the same person
as alt shift x but there isn't much
evidence for this fan theory
alt shift x is professional and concise
with
research and citations while alt swift x
is an unscripted rambling hot mess which
is why we don't normally promote alt
shift x on this channel
but some of these videos you might enjoy
there's also another stranger channel
called
random article it has some kooky
storytelling stuff
and some quote-unquote horoscopes that
have
an almost improvisational tone if you
like
weird stories you might like that
channel too
but the only true official alt shift x
side channel
is alt shift zed which has readings of
old books
like audio audiobooks the latest video
was the call of cthulhu by h.p lovecraft
there are also some scps some
non-fiction
some religious texts all sorts of stuff
all of these channels and videos
are linked in the description below
finally check out our sponsors curiosity
stream
and nebula curiosity stream has
thousands of documentaries about science
and history and nature
and nebula has exclusive content from
youtubers like tiazu volksgeist and
alt shift x nebula is an independent
platform where we don't have to deal
with youtube's algorithm
and demonetization and can try new kinds
of content
you can get curiosity stream and nebula
for a year for just 15 bucks
at the link below thanks for watching
and thanks to the patrons
including katie matthews jordan talbert
vincent and mapanao jr
zak krafzig torb michelle fairfax and
funky goalie cheers